[Music]
so Margo's pretty weird isn't he he's
part man part mascot part indestructible
bean and pretty good at every sport
imaginable if aliens ever came to earth
requesting the perfect life-form I'd
simply point them in the direction of
Mario and hope for the best
Super Mario Odyssey is right around the
corner and with our suspension of
disbelief already stretched thin with
the toll hat possession mechanic I
thought I'd take a look at some of the
most bizarre things that have happened
in the decades since the plumbers first
appearance as if eating mushrooms to
turn into a giant and possessing your
own logo wasn't already weird enough
here are the 8 strangest moments in
Mario history
Mario is no stranger to playing dress-up
but in Super Mario Galaxy we finally
come face to face with one of his more
peculiar costume choices one of the
games early worlds has you traveling to
the delightful honey hive galaxy in
which Mario Don's a bee outfit that
allows him to soar high above the plant
surface and by high above I mean a
couple feet since I assumed the out that
was not meant to support Mario's
considerable weight but more concerning
than the outfit itself is Mario's
interaction with the queen bee when
confronted the Queen requests Mario to
help her quote stop the itching of
course this can only be resolved in one
way yes Mario dressed as an animal must
climb all over a stranger he just met
this is upsetting very very upsetting
[Music]
and what's this rely on me in the future
get a damn back scratcher you pest
unfortunately dressing up as a bee
wasn't the only time we've had the
question Mario's wardrobe malfunctions
and the most egregious of them all might
be the cat suit from Super Mario 3d
World while we've seen them dawn outfits
mimicking everything from frogs to
tanukis to even insects watching a full
grown man get down on all fours and meow
like a cat is second only to toad doing
that exact same thing on the creepiness
scale I mean it's a great powerup don't
get me wrong being able to climb up
walls and execute a quick damaging dive
attack is actually quite useful in the
game but if your neighbor Mike decided
to strip down and squeeze his lumpy body
into a tight-fitting cat suit I'm sure
you won't be singing his praises would
you would you don't answer that in Super
Mario Sunshine the game pits you as
Mario against shadow Mario who actually
turns out to be Bowser jr. in disguise
after he drops the charade he also drops
from truth bombs on Mario and Peach
[Applause]
she seems surprised how do you not know
this kind of thing okay let's assume at
least that he's referring to her as a
stepmom since she has spent more than
her fair share of time being held
captive by Bowser
but if jr. is deluded enough to believe
that she is biologically his own mother
that raises way more questions than I'm
comfortable answering in one video look
I don't want to speculate on how that's
even possible any more than you do all I
can say is Bowser jr. certainly has some
daddy issues to work out oh wait he
already knows that Mario and Sonic have
a complicated relationship once
arch-rivals in the early 90s console
wars both spent much of the mid-2000s in
spinoff territory setting the respective
franchises on a collision course that
would see the meet in-game for the very
first time at the Olympics heavy is the
head that wears the crown
yes Mario and Sonic at the Olympic Games
despite being a breakthrough in mascot
ensembles is Peaks spin-off and possibly
rock bottom of both characters crossover
potential two franchises locked in an
eternal battle of BMX races equina
showmanship and track and field
really songs gotta lose a footrace to
peach she's not even touching the ground
Nintendo and Sega have been pretty
consistent in releasing these games
every two years to coincide with the
real world Olympics so it doesn't look
like they're gonna stop anytime soon but
for as weird as the series is you can at
least argue it's all been worth the
effort if only to see why Luigi
performed his graceful rhythmic
gymnastics routine while it may seem
like cheating to reference any game made
for the Philips CDI I mean those zelda
games are still getting crap today for
being made I feel like I have to add
this one to the list nine town T fours
hotel mario is perhaps the most poorly
written and crudely animated mario game
ever made everything about it seems
third-rate and it looks as if it was
cobbled together in ms paint using
rejected assets from the TV show
much like the equally awful Zelda game
for the same platform Hotel Mario is an
FMV adventure filled with plenty of
agonizing cutscenes
when you pitch with these pennies they
pinch back and the gameplay itself finds
Mario traveling to the Koopa family's
collection of boutique hotels which I
can only assume Bowser built with his
own hands since they all seem to fall
apart rather easily also real quick
shouts whoever named these levels the
Chilton blitz snarl tton seizures palace
okay points for these puns
anyway you complete each one of these
levels exactly how you expect in a Mario
game by closing doors I guess it must be
drafting in the building's because in
each hotel you take elevators from floor
to floor shutting every door along the
way that's all the game is yes even as
Bowser himself is breathing down your
neck flames and all you mustn't forget
to close the door behind you but how
about we just forget how it plays and
remember Hotel Mario for all the
wonderful jokes to be made at the
cutscenes expense you know what they say
all toast is toast toast in a stunning
new revelation regarding Super Mario
World it's been revealed by Yoshi's
creator himself that Yoshi is punched in
the head by Mario every time you make
him stick his tongue out
now this sheds new light on their
relationship and makes us all wonder why
the adorable green dinosaur even puts up
with the abuse I mean we know he's
capable of holding his own on the
racetrack so you have to wonder why he
doesn't just up and smack Mario in
return is this how you're gonna treat
the creature that tenderly cared for you
as an infant if that Simpsons Halloween
episode taught us anything it's that
cartoons should stay in cartoons and
transform them into the real world
simply make things look a little odd so
while the Internet has been making a lot
of noise about Mario going off to a
Newark like facsimile city in Super
Mario Odyssey and meeting real humans
Mario's off-kilter proportions versus
real-life people have already been
firmly established in MBA Street vol 3
the game pits Mario Luigi and Peach all
in their round cartoony glory against
players who look like regular humans
Super Mario Odyssey might have brought
more awareness to the characters odd
proportions but it's not the first game
to highlight the fact that despite being
in New Yorker Mario hasn't fit into the
real world in a
long time in speaking of real-world
depictions let's not forget Mario's
unfortunate forays into live-action
productions I'm sure it made sense at
the time to produce a huge summer
blockbuster for one of the most popular
video game characters on the planet but
did they really have to do it like this
aside from the terrible movie and the
questionably accurate TV show tokes
ahead is a hat
Mario also found himself among one of
the most popular television categories
of the late 80s figure skating
on Thursday December 7 1989 those who
are lucky enough to view it witnessed
the strangest and perhaps most hideous
display of videogame marketing ever seen
as the story goes a computer virus opens
up the seventh gate to hell allowing the
baddies from the Mushroom Kingdom ice
skates and all to come pouring into our
world Mario Luigi and Peach follow
shortly after because why the hell not
what follows is roughly six minutes of
absolute terror and surprisingly very
little ice skating Mario and Luigi after
descending upon the rink from the skies
determined that our world is important
enough to defend and fight back against
King Koopa and his minions the only way
they know how by in vaporizing them is
this cannon in retrospect the entire
production feels like one big fever
dream maybe it's because we're seeing a
teenage Jason Bateman hosting the show
or perhaps because the bargain bin
costumes were apparently made on such
short notice or maybe it's just because
figure skating shows are such a relic of
the past that Disney is the only one
capable of keeping the concept alive but
regardless the 1989 Ice Capades stands
out as one of the strangest moments in
Mario's history
[Music]
so those are our picks for the strangest
Mario moments of all time the Mushroom
Kingdom is a weird and wonderful place
so if you know a moment from Mario's
past that can rival Hotel Mario's
disastrous cutscenes or cat Mario's
feline prowess put it into the comments
below and for even more bizarre mario
things keep an eye out for our review of
super mario odyssey on gamespot calm my
name is joey and thanks for watching
[Music]